welcome back to led live have you ever
been in a tragic experience and
wondered where is god in all of this
jefferson county 911
[Music]
is
well thank you guys for tuning back in
and watching
led live and for those of you that are
new to this channel
if you like what you see don't forget to
hit that subscribe button we've got a
lot of different
topics coming out uh weekly every single
friday
today's topic is something that is
a very special topic and we have an
amazing guest
on on our show today you guys aren't
going to want to miss this
because i think it really illustrates a
really deep
deep thing of sometimes when when all
hell breaks loose and and you're in the
middle of this
absolute disaster it's it's it's
it could be confusing like where is god
why wasn't god there and i think after
you hear today's
testimony um you will see god is in the
very midst
of these tragedies many times and so i
want to introduce to you guys
um daryl scott whose daughter
was one of the students that lost her
life during the columbine shootings back
in 1999
and we are very pleased to have you on
the show daryl thank you so much for
joining us
thank you it's good to be here daryl
travels around the
the us and gives a lot of talks um i'm
sure you'll get a little bit into this
um and it has a ministry that really
centers around
a challenge that your daughter um had
had presented
and um it's known as rachel's challenge
and so
um tell us a little bit about uh uh um
your experience of getting involved in
in this type of work and and what it is
that you actually do
well i'll fast forward beyond the
tragedy to something that happened
to me at a service station at a gas
station
a gentleman asked me he recognized me
from television interviews that i've
been doing and he said
he didn't say it in a bad way but he
said where was god
when your daughter was killed at
columbine and
at first i didn't know what to say and
uh
you know the holy spirit always provides
you with an answer if you just
are willing to listen that's right and i
said he was the same place
he watched when his son died at calvary
and uh at the time that rachel died
by the way she was the first victim of
the first mass shooting
uh at columbine columbine was the first
mass shooting
of school shooting and rachel was the
first of 140 something victims now
over the last 21 years wow but rachel
was
sitting outside having lunch with one of
her friends
just outside the school when two boys
came over a hill
some kind of plan in the back of the
school and they had trench coats on and
they pulled out guns
and they opened fire they wounded dozens
of students who were setting out
on the lawn and rachel was the first one
to be shot and killed
and there was a lot of controversy over
who said what in the last moments but we
know
because the young man who was beside her
uh richard castaldo
who's paralyzed from the waist down he's
in a wheelchair
for the rest of his life but he told us
that
the gunman lifted rachel's head by her
hair
and said do you still believe in god and
she said you know i do
and then he said he shot her in the
temple
and she was the first victim to be
killed that day
wow but uh the shock that hit our family
you don't expect
uh to send your child to school and and
have have them
killed and i was in a shopping mall when
i got a phone call from my wife
saying that there had been a shooting at
the school and i rushed out to i was
gonna i had my truck i rushed out to my
truck
and uh turned on the radio and the
announcer said that up to 30 students
had been killed
which wasn't true but there was a lot of
turmoil at the time
12 students and a teacher died that day
and incidentally 2
000 years earlier another 12 students
and teacher had an impact on the world
wow
earlier yeah the first teacher was
called the son of david
the teacher killed at columbine's name
was david oh wow wow oh wow
now i i remember when i heard this story
um
and i want you to get into all this the
parallels
here that have these deeper spiritual
like applications um i was blown away at
had how many things had had popped up
that it was almost like
like like god had his hand over this
from the very beginning
and and so you know you're bringing out
all these little spiritual connections
but
but yeah definitely expand upon upon
that a little bit
um and and tell us about some of those
those kind of
connections well uh going back to the
teacher
david sanders was his name uh david was
was trying he laid down his life for his
students that day
and of course we know that jesus did the
same thing he laid his life down for us
but dave didn't have to die he could
have run
but instead he heard shooting on the
second floor
after my daughter had been killed and he
ran up the stairs toward the shooting
not away from it
wow this is the library where my son
craig
was with some of his friends and there
was no escape from the library that was
the killing zone
that's where most of the students would
be killed and he confronted the two boys
he had no way to defend himself
and he confronted the two boys and
begged them to drop their weapons
and uh when they refused to do that he
turned
they shot him in the back he stumbled
into a classroom
where he bled to death over the next few
hours and
the classroom that he stumbled into was
the science lab
it was the only room in the whole school
where there was a human skull and jesus
laid his life down for his students
and he was brutally wounded in the back
oh wow he died on the cross
and uh calvary is also called golgotha
which means the place
of a human skull skull
wow so those are just a couple of the
simple parallels
most of the children killed at columbine
have biblical names
and there's a lot more detail than that
but
uh it was such a shock to us as i raced
over to the school
in my truck i turned on the radio and an
announcer was sobbing
and saying that up to 30 had been shot
and killed
and i was doing the math in my head
realizing i had a nephew and a niece and
a son and a daughter
four students at that school and i was
thinking the odds are very slim that
that any of my children or my brother's
children
would be victims but when i got close to
the school they redirected us to a
an elementary school and they were
bringing busloads of students in
from columbine with survivors and uh we
waited and waited i i stood on top of
the fence
and looked in the windows as every bus
pulled in we heard from my son craig
and uh but we hadn't heard from rachel
and i watched as every student got off
every bus
and this dragged on into the afternoon
and at one point i thought i saw her i
was all excited
and then a little girl got off and
looked a lot like her
and we started calling the hospitals and
when your only hope is that your
child may have been wounded and being a
hospital
then you know you're desperate and uh
when the last child got off the last bus
uh we began to realize that we may have
lost rachel
and it wasn't until noon the next day
that we got official word
so we had 24 hours over 24 hours
where we we didn't know whether she was
alive or dead
and uh that waiting period was the most
agonizing day of my life
it's worse to not know than to know i
bet when i
when i saw this story um i have a
daughter
she's not quite a teenager yet but i i
was just imagining
you know my daughter in this type of
situation
and and it was just i i mean it just
like breaks your heart
to even just even think those thoughts
to
but to actually experience that and go
through that i i
i have nothing to compare that to i mean
i don't even know what that pain would
even be like
that i get a phone call from the
national media
and i do every time there's a school
shooting the minute i hear it's cnn or
fox news or
msnbc i know that there's been another
school shooting i usually know it
before the public knows it wow and the
heart always sinks and i
i feel of course for the victims but
also feel very deeply
for the parents because i do understand
what they're going through
and it's a it's a horrible situation my
son
craig was in the library which became
the killing zone
and he was with two of his close friends
and the
shooters came into the room and opened
fire
and craig my son craig
and his two buddies dove underneath the
table and
eventually they came to the table where
craig and his friends were
and they shot and killed his two friends
my son lay there
covered in the blood of his two friends
not knowing that his sister had just
been killed outside the school
and he knew that he was going to die he
looked down the barrel with two guns
aimed at his head
and he knew that his life was over and a
split second before they pulled the
trigger
the alarm system went off from smoke in
the room and it distracted the two boys
they never came back to the table
where craig was at or i would have lost
two of my children that day at columbia
oh wow
wow you know god is is
is merciful even in a situation like
this
um tell us a little bit about rachel
where
where where was she in her life leading
up to this experience
um what what what was kind of her
mindset and
um you know there were some connections
that you then later found out
by reading her journal and and having
some pictures and things tell us a
little bit about
where rachel was at um at the time of
this experience
well rachel was always one of those
children that
she loved to pick up a stray dog or
stray cat and bring him home
she had a tender heart and she was my
middle child i have two older daughters
and two younger sons
and rachel was the whole family knew
that
she was just she was the fixer she
always wanted to fix things that were
broken
in people's lives and she had that
reputation at school
for example uh at school she refused to
sit with any one click
she had a reputation for setting with
different groups almost every day
wow sometimes you would isolate a loner
someone that
always said by themselves and she would
go set with them and
today in our programming we've reached
over 28 million
students over the last 21 years and we
create what's called friends of rachel
clubs
in our schools and uh those clubs
one of the things they do is they
purposefully
uh commit on one day of the week to set
with people they don't normally sit with
if there's a new student at school uh
the four club will assign
five or six students to go meet that
student
and be with them throughout the school
day sit with them at lunchtime
and make them feel welcome but rachel
did that
she was uh she had she had had an
experience with the lord
uh at around age 12 that was very
powerful in her life
but it wasn't until she was 16 she kind
of
you know was a typical teenager from 13
to 16 but at 16 years old
a year before she died she began to
sense and feel
some pretty uh amazing things in her
heart
lord i'm sorry for everything that i've
done
jesus i asked forgive me and i asked you
to come into my life
father used me to be a light to the
world
and she began to write about them she
had kept a diary for a number of years
in fact we had
six of her diaries that she left with us
but a year to the day before she died
one year to the day april 20th 1999 was
the day she died
on april 20th 1998 she wrote in her
diary and she said
it's like i have a heavy heart there's
something in me that makes me want to
cry i don't know what it is
she said things have changed now that i
begin to walk my talk
some of my friends make fun of me but
you know what i'm not
ashamed of the name of jesus i'm going
to let my light shine and if my
and if my friends have to become my
enemies for me to be with my best friend
jesus
that's all right with me and exactly one
year later
uh one of her friends was one that shot
one of the two that shot
her uh had become her enemy and
caused her to go to be with her best
friend jesus wow
and she wrote a lot of things she in
that last year in her diaries
she wrote things like god i want you to
use me and i want you to use me
now she had a sense of urgency in her
life like
i don't want to wait it has to be now
and we have heard story after story
after story
from young people whose lives she
touched and changed
and uh i was just thinking the other day
uh you know we're in such a political
upheaval in our nation and we're there's
so much animosity between
the left and the right the conservative
the liberal
and uh and yet two or three of the key
figures
in politics today were influenced by
rachel
one of them was kaylee mcininnie who was
the chief white house
correspondent under president trump and
kaylee called
us several years ago and ended up being
on our board of directors
she had to resign when she became the
chief correspondent
or the spokesperson for the white house
but
she said that in in middle school
rachel's story
changed her life and all the way through
harvard school every thesis that she did
was on rachel
oh wow and then on the other side of the
aisle
uh camelia's harris his right-hand man
is uh sergio uh uh gonzalez who
garcia i'm sorry sergio garcia who
uh was a friend of rachel's in high
school
he was a young man that was gay and uh
rachel
accepted him as a human being she didn't
she didn't reject him like others had
and he never forgot that to this day he
and our friends on facebook
even though we have different political
viewpoints uh
sergio is now an influencer and then the
third one is charlie kirk who
uh has turning point usa charlie went
through rachel's challenge
and when he was in high school and told
me that it had a huge impact on his life
and helped guide the direction for his
life so rachel is still having an impact
on both sides of the aisle i think that
is so
beautiful that you know something that
easily could just
you your life would just fall apart as a
parent i just seems like
your life would would cease to
be interesting or exciting or anything
like this but yet something like this
has happened
and look at the amount of people now
that have been influenced or affected
or you know to to turn this tragedy into
something beautiful like this i think is
just
amazing and and that there is light at
the end of the tunnel you know
well i want to absolutely and and uh i'm
not taking away from the fact that i was
in deep grief yes since tomorrow for a
number of months
and uh there's a time to weep and
there's a time to rejoice
that's right that's ecclesiastes says
and uh we went through a time of
mourning
but we also uh knew that joy was coming
in the morning
and that eventually happened and but i
wanted to share with you
just how impactful your daughter still
has like you were saying
i i was 16 when this happened and i was
in a very dark place
i mean very dark like i was where those
shooters were
i was wearing all black i was listening
marilyn manson was my favorite band
and when it happened it it it didn't
affect me at all i was so
numb that even when 9 11 happened
i i'm ashamed to say like i walked in
and my mom was watching
the news and crying seeing people fall
down out of a building
and it just had nothing on me i i just
walked to my room like
whatever and i was like in such a dark
place
and it wasn't until literally like two
months ago that i watched this movie
that came out like four years ago and
all this
like brought back so much of my past
and and it just i was in tears the whole
time and when i finished watching it
i looked up all the interviews i watched
your sermon and i just spent hours
sobbing and just like
she was in such an amazing spot like as
a 17 year old girl saying
i want this now i want this now where so
many other teens are like
i got my whole life ahead of me i can do
that when i'm older that was my thought
when i
even when i started accepting that
christ was real i was like
well you know i can i can fully commit
on my death bed you know i want to live
my life
but rachel wasn't like that she wanted
to make a change now and she wanted to
um you know change the world with love
and compassion
and and and that would you know have an
impact on these
these guys that did this were bullied
all their life
or you know at least in high school or
whatever it's such an important message
for today because you think of what a
teenager's world is existing of right
now i mean it is like
centered around self-centeredness
selfishness
selfies everywhere and look at me and
look at what i'm doing
and to hear a story of a 17 year old
that says
though i lose my friends and nobody
wants anything to do with me i'd rather
stay true to the line of my best friend
jesus
and that's all that matters to me i mean
that is a refreshing story for me to
hear it's powerful man it's powerful
i i like how um you're encouraging young
people to
flip the model you know i remember my
family moved around a lot
when i was young and i was always the
new kid
and being the new kid in school is a
terrible thing
you know you're nobody wants to talk to
you nobody wants to get to know you
i think between fourth grade and sixth
grade i was in like 10 different schools
you can't make friends with anyone and
so
um you know there were very few people
that i can remember who actually would
do something like rachel was doing in
reaching out and trying to make you feel
comfortable
and welcomed and accepted so i
appreciate that you are
encouraging so many young people today
to to do that
um i remember watching one of your
interviews and you had talked about how
um rachel really wanted to be a uh
she wanted to be a movie star and at the
same time she wanted to be
um a missionary yeah and just what a
what a dichotomy of a world there
and please share with us how that
actually came true
well it did come true because uh
a movie was made about her life uh three
television emmy awards
uh based on her story so in that sense
how many how many stars win three emmy
awards
and at the same time she has become a
missionary because
her story in her life has changed the
lives of literally
millions of people many of them have
become
believers because of rachel's story we
we got an email
from a young lady who attended uh
one of our assemblies at school and she
went out and bought a book called
rachel's tears about my daughter
and she bought copies for her whole
softball team
and she emailed us and said that because
of that book her whole softball team
uh came to know the lord wow you know
it's
we hear stories like that all the time
one of the funny stories
we don't uh we don't screen our speakers
we have up to 50
presenters each year and we don't screen
them by religion
that we're a non-religious non-political
organization but one of them but we do
train them
we learn we train them to think
spiritually
and speak secularly which is really
important in today's culture
you can't go around spouting scriptures
of the young people they'll
they're immediately going to be turned
off but you can take any verse in the
bible
and reword it and if there's truth there
it's going to resonate in their spirit
like jesus parables yes absolutely
and so this young man came into our
office one day and he said
he was laughing he said i had the
strangest thing happened to me today
or yesterday when i was speaking at a
school he said
a lady came up with tears streaming down
her face this was in the evening event
because we do
a morning assembly we do a training in
the afternoon and we do an evening event
with parents and this was a parent who
came up to him
and uh tears streaming down her face and
she hugged him
and she said i want you to know that you
have renewed my faith in jesus
and he looked at me and he said as a
jewish believer
that i would be helping people renew
their
[Laughter]
also not just what's going on now but in
your daughter's death
brought so many people to the lord and i
heard a specific story i want to bring
up but
a lot of people say you know why would
god let this happen
and i've in the past mentioned you know
you don't know
when god allows somebody to die that
many people get saved at that funeral
god
is looking at the bigger picture and
he's like if a thousand people come to
the lord because of this one funeral
i'm gonna allow it and when you on uh
your sermon you mentioned that when cnn
or c-span whichever was was airing her
funeral
how it had more eyes on it than princess
diana's funeral
and you mentioned a man who was about to
kill himself will you share that
yes we we received numerous emails phone
calls
letters from people who actually gave
their heart to the lord at her funeral
all over the world because cnn uh
asked if they could broadcast the
funeral we gave them permission to
and uh it was the largest viewing
audience they had ever had in their
history
wow up to that point wow and uh we
we received so many letters and phone
calls and emails
i don't remember the specific one that
you're mentioning
but uh there were people who were
planning to commit suicide
who in fact one of the stories shortly
after she died the book came
out that uh that i co-authored called
rachel's tears
and a young girl a young lady
contacted us and told us that she picked
up the book it was lying on the table in
a bookstore
and she said i walked into the bookstore
an atheist
and i walked out a christian president
wow wow
lying on the table i sat down and read
the whole book without getting up
and i gave my heart to the lord at the
on the last chapter
that's a true missionary right there he
just heard so many stories like that
wow so i i want to to not skip over this
rachel's tears can you share a little
bit about um you know some of the
drawings that she had that you came
across
later um specifically the rose with the
tears on it and
and give our audience a little back
story on that yeah
about six to eight weeks after rachel's
funeral
i got a phone call from a gentleman by
the name of frank who lived in ohio
still does and uh frank told me that uh
he said mr scott you don't know me we've
never met
but he said i've had um he said
occasionally i have a dream
that i feel like the lord gives me and
it always seems to come true
and he said i've had a recurring dream
about your daughter
and her eyes and i've had the same dream
for over a week night after night and
i've shared it with my family and some
of my employees
and he said in the dream i see your
daughter's eyes
and there's a trickle of tears falling
from rachel's eyes
and the tears are watering something
that's growing out of the ground
there's life coming out of the ground
from her tears
and he said i just had to call and find
out
if that meant anything to you or your
family
and i told him no it didn't and he
apologized he said i'm sorry for calling
you i know you're still grieving
but he said would you please write my
name and phone number down
and if it ever means anything to any
family member
would you give me a call and so i'm so
glad i wrote his number down i did
and i put it in my desk drawer and
pretty much forgot about it
but exactly one week later i got a phone
call
from the sheriff's department and they
said we have your daughter's backpack
ready for you to pick up there were
three bullet holes through her backpack
and they had kept it as evidence
as to which bullets had done what and so
i rushed
over to get it and i took it to my car
and
i opened up her backpack and took out
some of her school books and there in
the bottom was our final diary
and like any parent i wanted to know the
last thing rachel had written before she
died
and so i turned to the last page of her
diary
and uh expecting to read something that
she had written
but instead i was looking at this
picture
and it's a picture of her eyes
there's a trickle of tears falling from
her eyes
and the tears turned dark just before
they hit a rose which is america's
national flower
and uh i counted the clear teardrops
there were 13 of them
and within two hours of rachel drawing
that picture
13 people had been murdered columbine a
teacher and 12 students
wow wow and when the
drops hit the rose they turned to dark
drops
that either looked like blood drops or
seeds
and for years i said that those were
blood drops
but i was speaking at a large conference
of educators
and a teacher came up to me afterwards
and said i don't think those are blood
drops i think they're seeds
because the man said he saw something
growing out of the ground
and so i changed my story
the man that called you was uh the
ironic thing is
the rose was growing out of a columbine
flower
and the columbine flower is the state
colorado state flower and the name of
the high school
wow but you have the america you have
america's
national flower growing out of the
colorado state flower
which happens to be the name of the
school and by the way the word columbine
means dove like it means like a dove
the same description used for the holy
spirit
like a god another one of those
parallels
but uh that's not the end of the story
because i was speaking at the old
country store which is the prototype
for all the cracker barrels in america
tennessee and uh the owners of the store
uh had a beautiful cabin they put me in
it's a cabin
they were good friends with the bush
family president bush
and that's where he stayed when he would
go fishing with him there
and i got to stay in this cabin by
myself i was wishing my wife was with
me because it was a gorgeous place and
it was right on the lake
but i spoke behind the old country store
they had made a platform
and tens of thousands of people
literally
were there it was a massive sea of
people and churches from all over the
area
had brought their folding chairs they
had a big pa system
outdoors and i told this story for the
first time and i didn't have any props i
didn't have any pictures i couldn't show
them the picture
when i finished telling the story there
was a little girl about rachel's
age sending over to my left right near
the front
who just started sobbing i mean loudly
sobbing
and people were emotional back then
because it was shortly after the tragedy
and i was used to that but i took note
of her because she was just
heavy and when i finished speaking
she came up to me with her bible open
and she said mr scott i was reading from
the book of jeremiah
three nights ago and the lord laid on my
heart
that the man who was coming to speak was
supposed to read these verses
you said i didn't know your daughter's
name i didn't know anything about you
other than that
you had lost your daughter at columbine
and she said now i understand why you're
supposed to read this
she handed me her bible and it was open
to the parent passage that said
a loud voice was heard in rama rachel
weeping for her children and refusing to
be comforted
because her children are no more
lord stop your weeping dry your tears
for your work shall be rewarded
and i shall return the children from the
land of captivity
and bring them back to their own
inheritance
that day i knew in my spirit what my
mission was for the rest of my life
wow bring children out of captivity
and bring them back to a place of their
true inheritance to find out
who they really are on who they want to
be
or who they think they are or who other
people say they are
but to get them out of the ego self out
of the self-centeredness
and into the spirit being that they are
and that's been our mission right and
that's where you will find
true happiness true peace when you're
others
focused you you you care about those
around you
you know like like in the film they they
often showed
one of the the schoolmates that that
rachel had that was
you know kind of disliked by everybody
and he was kind of
odd looking and and you know to to go to
those people and say hey what are you
doing this weekend
hey austin how's it going
going check chemistry
you want to do something this weekend uh
with who
with me can go like see a movie or
something
friday we would go on a a real
date yeah sure
have you ever been on one oh yeah lots
of them
i didn't know you're such a player i
wish my mom
got it i'm sorry i'm not your mom you're
prettier
you are a player you're friday austin
you know i'd like to hang out with you
and spend my time with you i mean those
little interactions
speak volumes to to those people you
could change someone's life
simply by that you know recognition and
and saying you know i i see you and i
care about you and
how can i make your life a little bit
better and to try to get young people to
understand that concept is
is our main mission on our on our show
as well so
um thank you so much for sharing that i
i do have one question
um what about the two gentlemen that did
this did you ever have any interaction
with their parents
i mean i wanna i wanna know what what
what is it like to forgive
somebody that took away your daughter um
you know what was that process going for
in your life
well fortunately for me i had great
mentors
uh i had a gentleman in my life
by the name of norman grubb he was a
best-selling christian
christian author back in the 1930s and
40s believe it or not
he was a world war one veteran he fought
for the british army
in world war one he won a number of
medals for valor
and uh norman was the uh
the son-in-law to a man by the name of
ct stud who was one of the first
missionaries
in africa and uh he also
was a close friend to reese howes and
wrote the story of
a man by the name of reese house who was
an intercessor
in wales and bought and helped bring
about the whales revival
norman was responsible for helping start
the presidential prayer breakfast but
when president eisenhower was president
and he was a a counselor to both
eisenhower and president jimmy carter
spiritual counselor to both of them and
norman
taught me something that i never forgot
one day we were talking he had a british
accent
and he said daryl if you will learn to
be a see-through
and not a look at her life will have
purpose and meaning
if you'll learn to see through your
circumstances
and not at them you'll find the hand of
god at work no matter what the
circumstances are
he said if you learn to see through
people to their heart
and not look at them their exterior then
you will know how to deal with them
and rachel knew that principle in fact
she wrote about it
she wrote about the illusions in life in
one of her writings and
she copied something that i had taught
she said
we talk about sunsets and sunrises but
there is no such thing
as a sunset or a sun rise those are
illusions
there's only earth turns but sunrise and
sunset
sounds so much more romantic and even
though we know
that there's no rising of the sun and
setting of the sun
before uh before you know 14
14th century everybody believed that the
sun rose and set
and uh so it wasn't until the telescope
that we began to realize
that the earth revolves around the sun
not vice versa
so she wrote about the fact that we live
in a world of illusions
and we have to learn to see through and
not look at
so when the tragedy occurred we had to
practice that
and it was really tough to practice
being a see-through
when we first lost rachel but one of the
first television interviews i did was
with maria shriver
and uh she grabbed us we were out near
rachel's car
which was still at the school and she
said mr scott
how do you feel about the parents of the
boys who did this
and i said well our family understands
the principle of forgiveness
and we've chosen to forgive wow and when
i said that
her head literally jerked back we still
have that video
wow and uh she said how can you possibly
forgive
and i said well i can't possibly for you
it's a divine attribute not a human
answer
and it's something that i had to yield
to in order for it to happen
yeah well larry king who just died
yesterday our day before yesterday he
saw that interview
and he invited me to come on his program
with billy graham and the two of us
talked for 30 minutes about forgiveness
oh wow
and then tom brokaw saw that interview
and he invited me to come on his show
for a 15-minute interview just on the
topic of forgiveness
so that topic alone was heard by the
whole world
through those three television shows on
the fact that you can forgive no matter
how terrible the situation and
forgiveness i pointed out
and i do a whole training on forgiveness
for educators
and uh we'll have 2 000 educators in a
room
and it's like a revival takes place
they're in tears they're hugging each
other they're crying
and i talked to them about uh the
difference between
pardon and forgiveness i would not have
pardoned eric and dylan
but i could not not forgive them
right forgiveness is for me that's right
martin
has to do with judicial procedure
forgiveness is an issue of the heart
that's right if they had lived and not
committed suicide that day
i would have gone to court having
forgiven them
and i would have testified against them
so that they could never do it again
that's right right yeah so people get
those two things mixed up
and they think well if i forgive it
means i'm supposed to let the person
continue to do what they do forever well
that's not always true
right yeah that's what consequences
sometimes they're for
but yeah the act of actual forgiving do
you feel that
a weight was lifted off when you
actually verbalized those
those forgiveness words and those
concepts and really just
gave that up to christ do you feel like
that that in itself was a release of the
of the just
anger and the frustration that you felt
or how did that
you know i wish i could say it happened
immediately but it didn't
i didn't feel forgiving when i confessed
forgiveness
i had to do it over and over and over
again and it took me to
the time when jesus told his disciples
if your brother
offends you yeah don't just forgive him
once yeah and then
which in essence he was saying you
forgive until it becomes real to you
right i had to do it over and over and
over
and uh i'm glad i did because it it was
like a slow
drip rather than a flood yes amen just
want to piggyback off of something you
said there all about forgiveness
you know with with each one of us god
has forgiven each one of us of our sins
and just like he forgives us of our sins
he's not asking us to
keep doing the same behavior over and
over again in fact he's telling us to
stop
go and sin no more you know so i can see
that
principle illustrated through how christ
treated other people on this earth and
what he calls each one of us to do every
single day
john wrote and he said that he shed his
blood not for our sins only
but for the sins of the whole world yeah
yeah
it says god who is the savior of all men
especially of believers that's in first
timothy
salvation has already taken place for
everybody yeah
and the good news is you're already
saved salvation took place at calvary
if i be lifted up i will draw all men
unto me
as by the the offense of the one the
disobedience of the one
the many were made sinners so much more
by the obedience of the one
shall the many be made righteous so the
good
news to all unbelievers is
guess what you're already saved and the
moment they acknowledge that
is when it becomes real for them yeah so
we have practiced that
in mexico uh a friend of mine dr mark
hamby
who's a one of the best preachers i've
ever heard in my life
uh he and i go to uh guadalajara
quite often and he led a family of
atheists to the lord there
and uh over the last three years that
family without a church building
have led as a result of that impact
over 30 000 new believers wow there's a
message to every one of them
and they meet by the hundreds every
weekend in different cities
uh and these are all new people not the
same people yeah people
and uh we begin to meet they begin the
meeting we don't do the meetings we
encourage them to do them and they begin
by saying
how many of you are baptists how many
are catholic how many are presbyterian
they all raise your hand
how many are atheists i'm your agnostics
and then they say here's the good news
no matter what your title is
jesus already saved you how many are
happy that he saved you
and he has to raise in their hands yeah
what happened just there yeah they
believed
yeah yeah our job is to accept with
believing
that it's already done yeah our job is
to accept that gift that christ has
given to us
right that's our job yeah daryl you've
made
so many amazing points and um earlier
you talked
about the programs that you do and that
you don't
use the label of bully and
that brought to my mind that's saying
hurt people hurt people
right and it's so easy to hate someone
who does something so catastrophic
and it it takes such a measure of faith
to as you're saying look through them
seeing god's love for them and then his
call for us to love them back
you know and um it brought to mind
romans chapter 12
verses 2 and 3 and it says and be not
conformed to this world
but be transformed by the renewing of
your mind have christ's mind
that ye may prove what is that good
and acceptable and perfect will of god
for i say
through the grace given unto me this is
paul talking to every man that is among
you
not to think of himself more highly than
he ought to think
but to think soberly according as god
hath
dealt with every man the mother of faith
and that was so impactful you also
said that you had to keep verbalizing
your forgiveness of these people until
it became a reality
and the thought came you know in this
silence there's compromise
and as a church as we go through these
times
throughout history these catastrophic
events
two things could happen it could shake
the church to its core to the
to the extent that it crumbles and a lot
of people lose faith
or it could actually like light the fire
of zeal that we need to go out and share
the love of christ
and have the holy spirit transform
people's lives and it's not just having
the the
renewing of your mind inside yourself
you need to verbalize it not only so it
becomes a reality for you
but to those around you to let people
know that no we don't agree with this
but we can see how god's working in this
and it is our part to um share the love
of christ with those
all around us evangelize right and also
you know as a christian you know you
don't have the promise of tomorrow
i mean when i hear this story you know
your daughter was prepared
she was god was preparing her and she
was
living her life as if it was her last
day and i believe that is something that
we all need to take a note on
and and live as if this was our last day
if if you didn't
know that you would wake up tomorrow
morning how would that impact
what you interact with today um if you
didn't know
you know that that you have that
guarantee when you walk outside and you
see that person
struggling on the side of the road or or
whatever how would that change
the way that we all interact together
and i think that's beautiful that that
rachel really grasped that concept
and even in her diary was writing in
there um you know i don't have much
longer to live
i mean what 17 year old thinks that yeah
you know though
i want to i want to piggyback off what
you're saying because
it if you if you look at rachel's story
rachel
rachel was at this point where she was
having to come to terms with
life and making a decision to go one way
or the other
and those two gentlemen who did what
they did they were also preparing
and you have a preparation for two
entirely different realities
and i think that's what everybody needs
to come to terms with in their own life
is what reality
are you preparing for are you preparing
for the reality that you're going to
submit to christ and love everybody or
are you going to prepare for the reality
where you reject his love
and and your life goes you know a
terrible direction
that's a great point because then you
look at the avenues
of preparation someone who is their
desire is to live for christ and what
was her avenue
she picked up her bible and she was
writings so
along with that i i just i feel a little
bit compelled to make this point
knowing knowing what those boys were
doing and and
how they were preparing they they had an
influence of media in their lives
so it was helping them to prepare and
they also were
reading some ideology that led them down
that path
and as i look at daryl here on the
screen i see a number of books in his
library
and how these books that he has read has
helped him
to prepare and become the person he is
today and
as our group we try to herald that
uh message that you know what you're
putting into your mind
affects how you think it affects how you
see life and it affects how you are
preparing
to live and what a powerful testimony
in both cases right of
how that mental preparation led them
down a particular pattern
and that preparation doesn't happen
overnight it's not like
all of a sudden wham it's this daily um
you know coming back and learning over
the course of time
and and and having those actions seeking
out those
those um undesirables in in the world's
mind
uh you know those kids in school and
daily doing that
that prepared her for that situation
what paul says you know says i
die daily that was his preparation
that's right
you know and look at the end result at
the end their earthly
end result of their lives both died
right
with the john 10 10 for the thief cometh
to steal kill and destroy
but god comes so he can give life and
give it more abundantly yes both were
put to rest
but both will have very different uh
realities when they wake up
well man i can't wait to meet your
daughter daryl in heaven
and i'm sure you can't wait to get
reconnected as well
thank you so much for for sharing um her
story with us
for continuing to to impact people's
lives with her um
tell our audience though a little bit
how they can get a hold of you
how they can get a hold of some of your
material you you'd mention that there's
a movie that was made on her there's a
book that was made
if people want to you know see some more
of of her story where can we get in
touch with you
well uh you're uh
somebody mentioned the verse from romans
about renewing the mind
and i believe with all my heart that
that's a neglected subject
and christianity because that's where
everything takes place
all temptation all guilt all judgment
all criticism all of that takes place in
the mind
and uh boy do we have some videos for
you
we have a whole channel dedicated to
this subject i wrote a book called lose
your mind
and find your purpose and uh it's based
on the scripture where jesus said
if you lose your life it's a
mistranslation
in english because the word life there
is the word psyche
it's the same word used for soul if you
lose your
psyche your mind because the mind is a
big part of the soul
if you lose your mind for my sake of the
gospels
you'll find the mind of christ
now you can contact me through
daryl scott books d-a-r-r-e-l-l-s
books or books by daryl scott
uh dot com or rachel's challenge either
one
and uh you can find a lot of videos on
rachel's challenge
and a lot of connection on daryl
scottbooks.com
uh on some of the books that we've
written about her well certainly put
um some of the links in the description
below do you guys have any other
final questions i want to make candy
does this last point
guys imagine this from god's perspective
right seeing all angles and having all
these moving parts and
not just rachel as a daughter but father
mother siblings
friends you know this expanding out to
now people in government and
all of these moving parts and it just
was laid on my heart that we need to be
obedient
to the lord you know imagine if that
person in ohio didn't pick up the phone
and call darryl and so he can make that
connection with what happened in the
diary like
that is just so impactful from the
biggest thing to the smallest thing
we need to be obedient to the lord and
follow the promptings of the holy spirit
and to
something tragic like that happens and
you don't understand
it's probably i mean you go through a
gamut of emotions i'm sure
angry at god where were you what were
you doing why did you let this happen
but then if you could just implicitly
trust god
exactly that he has our best interest at
heart
and that he can take a situation like
this and go and win a bunch of souls for
the kingdom
through this tragedy it's like no matter
what the devil does
he can't take the upper hand away from
god
god has the last voice and he's just
saying if you trust in me
i can turn this for good and it's okay
if it doesn't make sense
that's the thing sometimes it's not even
about us we just need to do our part
and it will create that domino effect to
impact someone way down the line
i mean not on your own understanding
that's right that's right
to all you young people out there that
are watching you guys
uh you're on our hearts in fact when we
in this ministry create any piece of
content
you are the ones that we are actually
thinking of and when we think about the
topics that we want to address the
things that we want to bring up
you guys you guys are the future and we
understand we've been past this teenage
college age range and we understand
through
experience of what that's like and
looking back on it from the perspective
that we have now
if you put your trust in god you will
have a peace that passes all
understanding
and god when you ask him to direct your
past he will
direct your path that's exactly what he
tells us in his word
so get in the habit of saying god even
though whatever tragedy is happening in
my life right now
i'm gonna trust in you i'm gonna place
my whole
heart and and and i'm gonna clasp on to
you until you bless me just like jacob
held on to christ that is literally
what we are called to do and i just hope
and pray that you were blessed by
today's topic
um leave some comments in the
description below if you guys want to
get in touch with daryl
reach out to him talk with him if you
want to read his book
rachel's tears great book check this
book out and there's also
a lot of different productions that have
been made about this story
and as always thank you guys so much for
tuning in
we hope that you'll like and share this
video and we'll see you again
next friday
[Music]
you